hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to rust now
I'm still here with Bob and we finally
survived the night night can't know
what's going on figure out what's going
on and now we are holed up in this Shack
alone and scared
and guess what Bob yeah what we're going
on a night hunt we're gonna kill animals
in the night what could possibly go
wrong a lot of things now if some
observant people might look and know
that hey I am more o'clock that's cuz we
tested out a method of which we could
kill animals in the middle of the night
and it worked so we're gonna go kill
some stuff but first I'm gonna go or I'm
gonna make a hunting bow Oh your stuff
to make a hunting bow yeah it just takes
wouldn't okay dang do you have five
cloth I have three cloth okay well I
have enough cloth give you that I could
help you make a hunting bow as well oh
and then it's just arrows which take
wouldn't don't I believe I have wood in
stone yes oh we could do this we can
actually do who needs wait wait oh oh no
wait no that's good who knees Wade huh
so how do I make a uh I'm gonna give you
some more but give me a second in 90
seconds to make arrows God and I'm gonna
drop my cloth on the ground you pick it
up and then you can make the bow and
then we can just chitchat while we're
wait I'm doing it I'm also I'm also
gonna make some arrows do you have stuff
for arrow no I'm making the arrows I got
it's just stone and wood takes forever
apparently but hopefully you can recover
it it only takes me 20 seconds to make a
hunting bow yeah but it takes me 90
seconds to make ninety arrows or nine
arrows oh why have a stuff to make nine
arrows to hunting with the bow you first
and we'll take turns
I'll do the running and then you do the
running and then I'll do the Ray the
thing is we run around with a torch
probably a beacon for any other player
in the entire server to shoot us dead
but that doesn't matter because we got
our little shelter year oh uh actually
do you have wood well
yes but I mean why do you ask uh uh yeah
here you go
oh thanks mm-hmm okay so I got oh I'm
not done yet
oh come on G I want a storage box to be
able to put my stuff away in I have I
have there are storage boxes in the
storage box there's just nowhere to put
them
you want to put some in your place put
them in mine I'm making I'm making seven
arrows yeah I got them on a go put them
in mine open the door please that
hatchet look very sinister up against
the wall yeah yeah yeah you're not gonna
take this seriously then I'm not gonna
take you seriously I guess I'll leave it
open hurry back
hang on I got it I got it hang on I got
it hang on I got it okay all right guess
I don't need my hand rock anymore I
guess we're beyond them got my hand rock
stone is that what you call it yeah
place this here why can't I place this
here really finicky just like going
around a little
okay oh you gotta you know I play this
game more than me I I did that already
so I know how to do that oh did you
figure out how to cook food honestly I
think I am cooking food right now I put
a bunch of chicken in the fire and I put
some wood in the fire and it started
doing the fiery thing so what I'm gonna
like do you realize how stupid that
sounds I know you're probably right but
do you realize how stupid those words
that's how cooking works whoo what was
that oh my god a deer just walked up
outside oh my god
[Laughter]
go nuts no arrows put him put him in
your action bar he's coming toward my
tour he's coming toward me wait I made
and they are not here they're gone oh oh
this is baloney
how are you ran away this is bullet
where did the arrows that I just made go
oh oh why do I stop the stones oh I gave
you wood in the middle
oh it was cool now I have to I have 28
arrows now oh oh oh no no no okay
I almost just accidentally shot one for
no reason yeah I have a hunting bow and
arrows check this hunting bow this is a
great idea wait mark the Sun is coming
up is it oh good either the Sun is
coming up or everything is glowing red
for no reason oh good get will you get
your torch out and just shut up just get
your just what are we gonna do this or
what we're gonna do this night hunt is
over because the barrel is gonna be day
but we're gonna do early morning hunt
like crack it on you know father-son
combo go so I can't see anything
alright fine I'll light your way all
right you see that deer over there no oh
yeah yeah you see it let's get a shot on
it you shoot all light
well you can't cast your light that far
I don't even know cash magic missile
into the darkness
alright you see it okay
well I guess let's both shoot Oh shet
that ruins everything no all the torch
oh dude no no no think it didn't notice
ah oh now it's pissed
[Laughter]
I will admit that was not much oh I
wanna is this a boar oh I need a torch
oh I can make low-grade fuel Oh where's
my animal fat I put in my gosh damn
dingdong damn
shelter you left your fire on is it
cooking meat got it okay all right okay
there we go okay all right where'd you
go
all right where'd you go I killed a boar
well good for you where'd you go I'm
over right over where the deer was I'll
get my torch out in a sec uh hang on I
gotta make a new torch because mine blew
up do you know how to make a torch how
do you make a torch you make low-grade
fuel mass this wooden cloth huh I'm
gonna need more wood eventually we're
both gonna need more wood okay there we
go got the torch oh it's surrounded by
trees how how hard up for wood can we
possibly be I know what I'm talking
about I'm gonna go kill some beers maybe
you go do your thing I'm gonna do a poor
no that's a boulder sorry I was very
mistaken I'm gonna hash it up this
Boulder ever figure out how to make a
furnace you need stones that's the wrong
menu how much cloth do you have well oh
well mr. borer are you ready for an
arrow of the ice hand low-grade fuel
that's the law well let me see how much
stuff we have for a beer no not a bar
dude you're killing me right in your
thing II know I can arrow it Oh still
mad I can make enough low-grade fuel to
make a furnace I'm okay that's lovely
I'm good I'm killing up yeah go save
your hug yeah I got it arrows are nice
how much how much stone do you have I
have I don't know music look at this
teamwork going on here I wish I could
hear all of the game here's the bunking
not every games down yeah someone's
thunking like oh no a server with 100
people we accomplished something over
and over I wouldn't get annoying hey
where's the camp the fires off yeah you
do I have yeah it's an endless bounty of
which there's a lot of blood here how do
I make med techs mid picks early I'm
brushing now look at your thing I'm
going okay Suns finally coming up over
the crest of the hill that's pretty cool
other day nice thanks for turn the fires
on in the night I went a bad direction I
think oh it's date oh we're in the
shadow of the hill is the problem if
you're in a well-lit area you need to go
towards the darkness and the shadow of
the hill and the fire is on are you
talking about man I'm giving you
metaphoric directions we're nowhere and
everywhere okay I always be okay over
there man a good thing we're in the
hard-to-find place because other players
will never be able to find us yeah we're
definitely not sitting out in the open
shut up don't tell anyone about this and
don't any of you tell anyone about this
we're never gonna be able to play on the
server everyone's gonna the server it's
gonna be friggin packed yeah that's how
it usually works like I do you saw what
I did for a world of warcraft right yeah
I did a live streaming I did world of
warcraft oh I should look over and I had
other fans come join me on this
and we had so many level 1 Dwarfs that
we actually crashed there were at one
point like it wasn't like the whole ever
went down it was just one zone and the
server went down but it was still quite
in ecology we had to have like at least
400 dwarves in there at one point you
turn on the fire again it's it's on oh
wait I see it is really hard to so it's
not on yeah it's really hard to spot for
some reason
alright this fire I'm gonna I'm gonna
test my theory again okay
I'm gonna test my theory this time I'm
gonna put some ore in it and see what
happens
okay well that's lovely right did you
make a furnace no I don't have enough
stones to make a furnace
I made the low-grade fuel you were
clapping stones to make a furnace how
much don't you have I have two and it's
in the chin to the chest thing we need
five we need three more than I need to
go out and get more but I'm about to die
of starvation
so why if your food theory works that'd
be lovely yeah well it's not done
cooking yet apparently I'm not sure
exactly but all right I'll go die
looking for
okay well putting putting metal ore in
the thing it's not doing anything in the
wire in the butt can I put blood in the
fire no all right so what is the point
of this what's the point
I mean the fire is still going I am out
of food I can't swing my hair well just
pull all your valuable stuff in here and
die in come back maybe you should just
kill me like all my stuff will drop in a
convenient box on the ground okay well
come here I just finished harvesting a
board I'll be over there so that you can
murder me horribly in no time
let's go where'd you go oh there it's
really hard to spot was everything
alright that's because I'm so stealthy
kill me one sec I'm playing with my wood
hard
right between my bazooms hit me
comfortable yeah you're comforted by the
fire it's comforting that is lovely
it's comforting right that on my down
there
mark died in the comfort of his own
campfire and I made for him it's a dead
body it's your dead bodies backpack so
do you have stones or what now I have 10
stones I wasn't able to find more before
I thought I thought 10 was all we needed
did you look oh we need 15 total that's
accurate we also need 20 wood which we
don't have but I will get I have wood
but like I don't even I don't see any
stone I'm gonna have to go far for stone
so BRB honey dear I'll go get the stone
don't get lost
it'll be very easy anyone no one is here
did you hear it I guess that's about how
it is when you talk in real life good
look at that look at me look at that I
can't find any stone deposits there's
nothing so I keep making Dave Chappelle
a reference spell that guy's still funny
when he was on that show minam anthea
that was great man I missed that guy
I uh I whatever whatever whatever man
George Carlin what an [ __ ] that guy
dead did you take your backpack or what
I didn't take the backpack I took things
out of the backpack oh I'm gonna take
your clock
oh those are hands man stones you know
stones for hand stone stuff I'm always
gonna keep my hands you never know in
real life when you might need a hand
stone I can make a cloth helmet oh my
gosh
I'm gonna make all my weight we really
do there we go you make low-grade fuel
with clock we have enough low-grade fuel
for the furnace and oh yeah you do yeah
I'm gonna make myself
sure you bid are not a shirt apparently
I can only make a vest okay I don't need
that you know we would probably much
more expeditiously Aidid if we went
through a place to forage for stuff I'm
just gonna stand around okay all right
fine whatever
Oh suddenly suggesting that maybe you
should get off your ass and help us out
I like standing around fine whatever you
know what kill this board oh my gosh oh
my gosh what Oh cooked chicken breast
exists on my screen it was right I was
right
you're right but I was right how many
did you make
I have six cooked chicken breast and it
has to do it has to do with how much you
would you put you have to put wood in
and then stuff in yeah well shut up no
no we could set up a whole bunch of
campfires and do it that way well that
was kind of my idea I'm gonna I'm gonna
I need some work
see I'm the homemaker and you're the
provider because I'm not providing very
well you provide and I will home make
you make the home there's a compound
down here I'm gonna go see if it's
irradiated and then check it out as the
provider I'm gonna lose all this stone I
got when some other player comes up it's
good that's perfect thank you I try real
hard no radiation yet
Rad's are going up now if there's lots
of radiation but I'm gonna duck in here
real quick see if I can grab them
ooba-dooba do ring ring ring ring ring
Nanna phone should be debited oh no no
no no radiation prone it's so enticing
although my face is melting there's not
a single damn thing here anywhere all
right
ding dong ding dong ding dong ding I'm
hot I'm not hungry
and I did it myself you did it all by
yourself did it all by myself I tried my
best
that was actually a Dane Cook joke
what's go figure I don't know I think he
died oh yeah I don't think he died
that's a lie that's a lie but let's
start that rumor people just realized
he's not that funny oh man all the trees
around our area are all empty you see if
I can kill one of these D yeah if you
guys saw that mist it was the messiest
miss I've ever seen in my life it was
like right in front of him and he like
shot completely I thought he was gonna
start running so I found a stone in
front of our house you jackass with the
misting are you even trying to provide
for the home and make it
oh no response I see how it is ah shut
up I got it okay good
Wow now that it's daylight our house is
very obvious now we're gonna die but I
got lots of ammo so that's good for us
I'm gonna store it all in my cabin I'm
gonna actually dump off a lot of stuff
that I don't need to carry on the road
yeah can we put another storage box in
your house and fill it up because I've
got I've got to write the one in my
house is completely stuffed
so there's a whole bunch of rocks out
here dude oh really like I see three
right now what they spawned it wasn't my
fault they just happen to you don't fat
me I will not do anything because you're
the lovely homemaker dear some cooked
chicken in the chest for you too
ok I'm gonna split in the chest in my
house figs honey you're the best dear no
I got lost what I guess I'll put the
bags up below I'm not lost I'm just
stupid oh don't say that honey bear when
I hear footsteps I think it's like I'm
very concerned okay mine is locked and
closed so I have stone can we make this
furnace now I actually have enough stuff
materials of my own oh do you have any
wood oh yes how much can you give me ten
more there's 80 - oh I'm such a provider
alright check this check this down I'm
gonna I think I can make a furnace right
no thank you this if we get shot at
remember the emergency oh no it's 15
stones and I got it I got here only 16
stones baby oh my gosh it only takes 30
seconds to make a whole furnace Wow
okay remember emergency protocols if
someone starts shooting at us close the
door
yep have fun out there oh come on no
one's shooting okay whatever only have
five arrows left I go stable I'm gonna
make him a lot of arrows
you got the furnace it's crafting time
10 seconds left bra also I have 18
throws it's zero it's it's done yeah I'm
gonna go I wonder if I can put it in my
place oh my gosh Wow Wow
I mean all we used was was food huh I
just need a cooked chicken okay 500
chicken are like friggin gold
let's make all barges I'm making like
almost 50 cooked chicken oh my god so
what is the what is the furnace how do
we use the furnace
well how you use the thing I've got
metal or over here hang on let me go get
it metal or I've just got I've got 39
metal or and 50 for self sulfur or I
just stuck in there but okay it's not
doing anything I don't want to put all
this wood in yeah doesn't need all my
wood know what it feels like oh we're
way over time dude okay we'll figure
this out in the next episode we're
making progress
[Music]
[Applause]
you
all right doing good yeah this [ __ ] not
bad okay well surprise doughnuts coming
well don't say anything so hopefully
we'll be left alone here I mean it's a
big map with not many people so
hopefully it'll be fine I think maybe
possibly alright you ready to start
again just go ready to the next one what
do you want it that's all up to you I
mean whatever you wanna do can I have
some of those stones back though I need
to make some arrows yeah
blur birdy they're actually like we can
make how do we make low call it how do
we make metal right that's what I'm I
think it has something to uh oh oh I
turned the furnace on it's furnishing
cuz we put fuel in it already right yes
okay so that's I think that's how we
make metals right oh all right
okay god oh my god